When I came to the clinic in August 2021 with all my supplements I was
currently taking the only one you told me to stop taking was the homocysteine
resist. Now one and a half years later turns out my functional doctor was
corrected prescribing this and I'm going back on it. Thanks to the Dutch test in
the homocysteine test results. But can you give me some insight as to how my
uncorrected low methylation impact my general health cancer and detox these
last 18 months. I don't understand much about methylation though you speak
often about the danger of over methylation. What are the issues of low
methylation? What might I expect now that this is being corrected again? Well
you might not you probably won't see as far as what you could expect from me
corrected again you probably won't have any symptom changes like changes you
won't notice anything. The idea that so here's why you don't want to be on
methyl groups to any methyl groups when you have cancer methyl groups so a methyl
group is from a biochemistry standpoint as a CH3 actually looks like that when
you would you know but from a biochemistry or get a chemistry standpoint that is
a methyl group that attaches to different components now what I'm what met
then what you have with different methyl groups that you take like a product
called methyl covalomide which is a methylated B12 or methyl tetrahydrofolate
which is a methylated folate is you have methyl donors so those products then
donate methyl groups to your cells. What happens in your cells is those methyl
groups function inside the cells at the nucleus of the cell and they help
silence genes they turn off different genes which is good and bad if you have
cancer and you have excess methyl groups you stand the potential of turnied off
what are called tumor suppressor genes tumor suppressor genes are genes that turn
on when there's cancer growth and what they do when they turn on is they help
cause a poptosis of the cancer cell and help kill the cancer cell so hence if you
have excess methyl groups circulating in your body you will be silencing
tumor suppressor genes and by silencing tumor suppressor genes you could
propagate a cancer so you could increase the growth of an existing cancer you
could increase the likelihood of cancer it's just like okay when women have you
know bronca genes defects under bronca genes what are the bronca genes?
Bronca genes are just one tumor suppressor gene if you have defects under your
tumor suppressor genes they have the potential of not working as well as if
you didn't have defects on them so if you did develop a cancer cell in in your
breast let's say and it starts to grow and you have defects in the tumor
suppressor genes they're not gonna work as well what do they do they're supposed
to turn on and cause a poptosis cell death of that can't growing cancer well
also you could have perfectly healthy bronca genes and no defects whatsoever
but you are over-methylating because you did a genetic test and it showed a
MTHFR defect so then your naturopath or chiropractor said well you need to
be on methyl comolivated methyl folate that's your problem and you're over-
methylating and you are basically silencing tumor suppressor genes well it
gets worse on that because if you have defects on your biopsyroid pathway which
is a different metabolic pathway that make that biopsyroid pathway is how
you make all your neurotransmitters so you're dopamine and you're serotonin and
your GABA and all that you over-methylation pushes that pathway and you'll make
excess of that which can cause severe emotional imbalance and rage issues and
anger issues and PMS issues and mix that with any other hormonal imbalance and
you have a cocktail of you know lots of issues so I'm not in favor of simply
using excess methyl groups to deal with the MTHFR gene defect the only reason why
I would suggest you use methylated vitamins is if you have homocyst elevated
homocysteine so that would be the only reason to take methyl groups of my
book and even if you have elevated homocysteine you have to balance that with
well I also have cancer so then okay well you know where's my risk reward here you
know if your cancer is fairly stable then certainly use methyl groups but if to
help lower your homocysteine levels but you do want to be re-checking your
homocysteine levels on a regular basis probably every few months to simple blood
tests to do to make sure you're not you know taking it for no reason whatsoever